[Musik]
von dem und ich bin begeben musste
hallo also darf ich ja gar keinen bock
drauf
hey leute ja
leute
das artikel 13 das war's nicht
[Musik]
dieses
hallo
er ist nämlich morgen schönen guten
abend
fangen wir mal an also nächste woche
sind die nächste woche sind die
offiziellen demos gegen artikel 13 23
sind in deutschland berlin am potsdamer
platz so 14 uhr
köln am neumarkt lose 14 uhr also
österreich ich habe mich mit der ganzen
scheiße jetzt nicht krass auseinander
gesetzt ja du also ich glaub da jetzt
müssen wir müssen wir da müssen wir da
müssen wir jetzt einfach mal versuchen
ein geschäftsmodell euch ausgesucht wo
es zu massiven urheberrechtsverletzungen
kommen dass er wirklich relevant dafür
müsst ihr die verantwortung tragen dafür
musste lizensieren und wie ihr das macht
ist eure sache aber ist das dümmste was
machen kann weil er stark sehr gut sehr
gut youtube ist das einzige was mich was
mich so ein bisschen werd ich mache
warum leute mich auf einmal ansprechen
es ist einfach so ja es gibt in dem
sinne nur diese dating plattformen oder
was auch immer das daran plattform
liefert der musik sehr gut ich gehe mal
kurz piste ok was mache ich ohne youtube
wenn ich mit youtube auch für die
zigarren muss für frauen mit fenstern
gibt ja also ich sag mal so als ich noch
jung war habe ich mir auch schon mal ich
sagen wenn ich dann wieder luft dringt
in immer in mein zimmer sitzen weil ich
nach dem machst du pillon keine luft
mehr bekommen weil ich so fett bin ich
mich immer daran ja nix was hast du das
ruf allah das ist jetzt zu viel
informationen ganz ehrlich hat wichtige
13 kraft treten sollte dann sage ich
wieder schauen reingehauen total scheiße
habe ich alles schon erlebt ist komplett
scheiße leute ist scheiße weißt du diese
ganzen politiker arschlöcher die da
sitzen dicke von dem was worüber sie
entscheiden gar keine ahnung hat und nun
wirklich der vom tuten und blasen keine
ahnung vorbei zweiter ist vielleicht
doch schon ja nicht mal dass leute jetzt
war alles okay
mit anderen worten lange rede kurzer
sinn diese kampagne wird weiterlaufen
dieser unsinn über filter wird genau so
weiterlaufen wie bisher
ok mega mega der wirklich platzhälfte
nur wir müssen hier noch mal festhalten
dass die identifizierung software kein
filter in europa und dann nach seinem
bruder als ordner ja kein bock mehr auf
diese scheiße wo leute ganz ehrlich
gehören auch ich bin nämlich nicht
unbedingt dass ich bin ich mal so laut
wie sauer und ich hab einfach ich habe
einfach keinen bock mehr ich habe zwar
keinen bock mehr grössenordnungen die
deutschland und frankreich als kamerun
bei der kürzlichen meisten dann von
allen abbruch abbruchs reicht mir das
ein scheiße das war natürlich eine
youtube kacke wie ihr offensichtlich
gesehen habt und es war der zweite teil
von einer serie zum ersten teil geht
hier oder hier hier oben hin ergeben das
war nämlich eine zusammenarbeit mit dem
guten freund und geht morgen übrigens
auf die demo seht hier wann und wo dies
sind zum beispiel am samstag und hierzu
in köln ist sie da sind wir auch am
start ist ja nicht allein hingehen also
schnappt euch ein paar kumpels ist
weiter wir morgen mittag allesamt so ich
arbeite weil gerade ein schnitt kursen
also wenn ihr auch mal youtube-kanal mit
videos schneiden lernen wollt dann seid
gespannt da kommen nämlich kurs auf euch
zu jetzt auf jeden fall den ersten teil
einer beschreibung ab und dann wenn ich
mich auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
dann abonniert diesen kanal und dann
sehen wir zunächst mal wieder macht gut
[Musik]